[موسيقى]
موجز الاخبار من قناه الجزيره اهلا بكم
قناه مصادر طبيه اسرائيليه
في محطه حافلات عند مدخل القدس 22
معنا من القدس مراسله الجزيره نجوان
السمري نجوان هل من معلومات اضافيه
بدات باعمال البحث
الاول للشرطه
الاسرائيليه
الحديث يدور عن انفجار واقعه قرد محطه
حافلات رايسيه عند المدخل الرئيسي لمدينه
القدس من الجهه الغربيه
الحرجه تم نقل الغالبيه المصابين الى
المستشفيات الاسرائيليه بالاضافه الى
تعامل همم
طارق اقل من الساعه وقع هناك انفجار اخر
في منطقه اخرى في مدينه القدس
نموت خلفيه هذا الانفجار الثاني
سالت قيد الف صحه هذه اللحظه وبحسب
المصادر الطبيه الاسرائيليه لا توجد
اصابات جزاء هذا الانفجار الشرطه
الاسرائيليه اغلقت المدخل الرئيسي لمدينه
القدس واغلقت مقطع من شارع محوري ورئيسه
وشارع رقم واحد الذي يصل بين مدينه تل
ابيب ومدينه
القدس وتواصل عمليات التحقيق من خلال جمع
دي كاميرات المراقبه في المنطقه وجمع
شهادات من شهود عيان الاجهزه الامنيه
الاسرائيليه تعمل
بكل اجراها الشرطه
والمخابرات وقوات اخرى هناك حاله من همم
الصدمه في الشارع الاسرائيلي جلال هذا
الانفجاران صباحا هذا اليوم في مدينه
القدس وانه لم تكن هناك معلومات
حول هذا العمل حتى هذه اللحظه همم نتعرف
على المزيد لاحقا بكل احوال نشوان سمردا
مراسله الجزيره كنت معنا من القدس شكرا
جزيلا لك ختام هذا الموجز مشاهدينا الى
اللقاء